WIN AGAINST THE GOSTISBEHERE
AND KESSEL.
PHIL THREE WIN AND IT
IS JUST GETTINGELLER TO THE FRO
SCHMALTZ A SHOT, AND
GOSTISBEHERE AND DUO OF
KELLER AND SCHMALTZ, AND CLAYTON
KELLER IS GOING FOR KELLER.
TRYING TO HOOK UP WITH SCHMALTZ
AND THAT'S TO THE CORNER B THAT
PLAY RIGHT THERE.
AND THEN THE TURNOVER.
WRONG ZONE, CONNOR
BROWN AT CENTER, BUT
GOSTISBEHERE ON  JUICY REBOUND
THERE, AFTER THE NOT SURE WHAT
YOU ARE EXPECTED TO DO.
>> OH, AND SCOTT WEDGEWOOD IT
LOOKING UP AT THE TO SWAT AT ITT
BRADY TKACHUK.
NOWBIG POWER PLAY GOAL FOR OTTA
WHO NOW HAS SOMEOUT.
>> CHABOT, TRYING TO GO WIDE
ONE, GOOD SPEED A AND THAT DEFL
OUT AND GET THE GOAL.
>> BACK OUT
AND THEY GET A REAL NICE BOUNCE
ON THIS ONE ALONG BY DYSIN MAYO
HE'LL SEND IT IN.
>> I THINK THE TRIP YOU WERE THE
WRONG GUY, NICK SCHMALTZ.
AND HE SCHMALTZ WILL BRING IT O
THAT'S A HEADS-UP PLAYO IS UP T
TERMS POINTS NOW FOR
AGAIN. A RIPPER BY MAYO.